Let's go to oh, I want to go to John from
Philly, Nuestro Amigo, Dominicana John from
Philly.
How are you today, my friend?
Hey, baby.
How are you, sir?
Good.
How are you?
Do I have a question for you?
Yeah, I don't I have been have been brought
to you before.
Why?
I am a Democrat.
Why do the Democrats sometimes in politics
are so weak?
I don't know.
Like I can analysts blame a weak or being
or whether or, you know, I'm basically being
nowhere for for the Republicans to do anything
they want.
It seems to me like this is all all right.
They're done because even when they are not
in power.
Yeah.
I mean, when they are even in power, they
when they daily House, the Senate, the presidency
is even more important than grand schooling
or for any delay.
And they seem to relay easily.
No lives.
I don't know how I got a splash.
Now you're you're really explaining it beautifully.
I don't have an answer for you.
I wish I had.
So here's the one thing I would say, John.
There's something to be said for not stooping
down to the level of the right.
Like, I understand the concept of the right
to lax morality.
They are total hypocrites.
They'll do whatever the hell they'll say.
One thing in 2016 in order to prevent a nominee
to get on the court and then they'll say something
different.
Like, they have no morality whatsoever.
And there's something to be said about not
stooping to their level.
But you're bringing up a good point, which
is at some point, don't you need to start
winning?
Corera, like they.
I mean, is a was Leray was just cruising over
all the time.
Yes.
When we lodged the they arrived.
They may have.
They, they have.
They very started to doing anything filthy
you know.
Yeah.
But the problem is, you know, I do think that
the problem is if the left uses the right's
dirty tactics to win, aren't we as bad as
they are in some sense?
I don't know.
I don't know the answer to that.
Yeah, maybe they're right.
But I share your concern.
I share your concern in what's going on now
with the Supreme Court is it's it's disgusting,
but it's also totally predictable.
Right.
Correct me, IRA.
Yeah, I agree.
John, are you voting in person by mail?
What are you doing?
I'm thinking to going to vote in person.
OK.
We will see how fast going.
And will you try to do early voting or November
30, think?
I don't know, because in Pennsylvania, I don't
know when they open the right.
Go on.
Go in person.
I think it's too soon.
I think it's very sad.
Is very soccer, I think.
Why is that?
Well, I will I'm going to you know, I'm going
to do it.
You do it.
So as soon as I can.
All right, John, I appreciate the phone call.
All right, David, you have a wonderful day.
Thank you.
You, too.
Take care.
Bye.
There's John from Philly, originally from
the D.R.
We love John.
Let's go next to our caller from the three,
four, seven area code.
Who's calling today from 347?
Hey, David.
My name is Michael, and thanks for taking
my call.
So I am a committed Democrat.
I'm Michael.
I'm sorry to have to interrupt.
You're going to have to you're going to have
to back away from the phone a little or drop
your voice down to a more reasonable level
of your your.
I'm about to blow an eardrum.
Oh, no.
OK.
So I'm a committed Democrat, 66 year old native
New Yorker, and I have one major concern.
Yes.
So do you think that the Democratic Party
is really, really prepared with strategies
to deal with the Red Mirage?
Right.
OK, let me explain what that is to people
so.
So Red Mirage is the idea that because Biden
voters are much more likely to vote absentee.
That you could have states where it's close,
where on election night Trump has a small
lead.
And then in the days that follow, as the absentee
ballots are counted, Joe Biden takes a lead.
And the fear is that in the intervening time,
Donald Trump will use the lawyers.
We know he has ready to go to try to stop
the counting of absentee ballots or do other
things.
So your question was, do I think Democrats
are ready to deal with that?
The answer is no.
I think that they are partially ready.
We did get a report late last week that Joe
Biden and the Democratic Party are getting
numerous lawyers ready to try to deal with
this.
But the problem is that you fundamentally
have an advantage if you're playing offense,
because you know what the strategy is.
If you are playing defense in this case, by
definition, you're at a disadvantage because
you're playing defense against what you believe
they are going to try.
But they may try things you're not prepared
for.
So I think that on a scale of one to 10, the
left is probably at a five or six in terms
of being ready to deal with Red Mirage.
OK, so if I could go further with my question
on, you know, how.
For example, when Democratic candidates are
preparing for debate.
Yeah.
And what like, for example, right now, you
have people to judge supposedly is helping
Kamala Harris and he's playing the role of
Mike Pence.
Right.
And what they're doing is they're practicing
and they're anticipating, like one anticipates
chess moves.
Sure.
So if that's the approach.
So I would like to.
I would think that we would be needing to
do that, anticipating a variety of different
moves.
No doubt we would have to make because as
you correctly stated, we're not going to know
exactly all of the things that Trump will
do.
And yes, they because there are no sense.
You're absolutely right.
But I'm just wondering, is there anything
that any of us could do?
I'm just an average citizen.
You have a prominent position in the political
world.
But I'm just wondering, is there anything
that that can be done to get the message across
to the leading other leaders of the Democratic
Party that they need to be fully strategizing
in every single way possible to anticipate
every possible move the Republicans may make.
So unfortunately, I think on this one being
so close to November, if the Democratic Party
doesn't already know that they need to be
ready for this, I don't know that there's
much we can do.
I think what we can do is to make sure that
at the individual level, people understand,
for example, if you are in line to vote before
polls close, you can vote.
Don't be tricked into being told you can't
vote.
Right, because this is how they could they
could do affect turnout.
We need to sort of inform people at the individual
level because we're only six, five and a half
weeks out at this point.
If the Democratic Party is not ready for Red
Mirage, it's over like there's nothing you
or I at this point can do.
Sadly, I hope that they are ready.
I don't know if they are.
Yeah, well, a my obviously my concern is not
alleviated, but your answer is absolutely
right on the money, as usual.
Thank God.
So anyway, thanks for what you do.
You have a great show.
And I just love your clarity and your analysis
and New York contribution to the political
discussion.
So valid.
So keep doing what you're doing and I wish
you all the continued success.
Pleasure having you on.
I really do appreciate the phone call.
Let's take a quick break.
If you are holding and that's an F. Don't
hang up because we're going right back
to
the phones momentarily.